Next, let's touch upon the material system and the parents and instances that encompass
that.
So, the topics here are the material editor, parent materials, and material instances.
And so, the material editor is an intuitive node-based editor.
We can create HLSL shaders without any need for any kind of coding.
It's all represented through the visual node graph that you can see on the right hand side
here.
We can organize the material graph with comments and descriptions and make it very clean and
easy to read and you can kind of pick apart the flow and understand exactly what's going
on in material editors, which again, like I mentioned at the start, we'll touch upon
towards the end in the material editor section.
So when we're talking about material, a parent material, a parent material is an asset that
you end up with when you save the node tree from the material editor.
So the image that we saw on the previous slide, if we saved that, that would become a parent
material.
And you typically adjust a parent material to behave based on a series of criteria and
properties you define such as input options for whether it be base color, which is the
albedo, metallic, roughness, normal, you know, et cetera.
Any of those inputs would list it above.
So even though you can apply a parent material directly to an object, you can usually create
an instance derived from it that you apply instead on the scene.
So the parent material houses all the instructions and the instance can then be a more optimized
way of using that because parent materials are essentially heavier to use.
They require recompiling every time you change them.
Whereas an instance, you can edit on the fly and you can change different parameters
and you don't have to recompile the entire shader because the shader already knows what
it needs to do.
The main thing to take away though is to adopt a naming convention when naming your parent
material so you understand in the editor, you know, whether you want to use M underscore
for material or mat.
Some people use mat underscore.
Just whatever name and convention you think of, keep it consistent so that everyone can
understand the difference between a material and a material instance.
Unreal does have a way of filtering these things out, but it's sometimes just easier
to see from the naming convention what this material type is.
And so giving you some hot keys for your material editor, maybe you want to take a screenshot
of this or note them down.
There's some useful node shortcuts here to take away.
It will create them, especially if you're using the material editor a lot.
These kind of things will save a lot of time.
And then talking about material instances, instance materials inherit the properties
of a parent material they are based upon.
So you can set the parent material in such a way to have total control over the parameters
and expose them in the instance.
And we'll talk about what this looks like at the end of the course when we actually
create our own material instance, but it essentially means that you can have any number of material
instances based on a single parent and have totally different looks and finishes.
So it really helps you dial in the different values that you want using the instance instead
of that parent material.
So material instances, as mentioned, are much lighter to work with and can change at playtime
without the need to recompile the parent material.
And a material instance UI is simpler to use.
It's just a much more streamlined set of commands that you can use over the node-based material
editor.
As mentioned previously, you just want to make sure that naming convention is set when
you're using material instances.
So we use MI for material instances.
So M underscore for material and MI underscore for a material instance really just helps
people, well yourself as well, but people on the project understand what the different
materials material types are and how to use them without having to hover over to find
the information or double click it to open it up.
It's just a much more streamlined way of working.